Companies like Google could become
completely irrelevant.
>> Yeah.
>> Or they could just become juggernauts
even more.
>> Yeah.
>> They're not like institutions that are
going to last no matter what happens.
That's what I'm trying to say. I think
they seem like infallible. They felt
like
>> I don't know.
>> They have to keep winning.
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> Yes.
>> This is Dolphin Plus Michael. Today
we're going to talk about predictions
that turned out way better than we ever
could have imagined. specifically ones
that maybe in hindsight look a little
bit more obvious, but at the time
one or both of us didn't quite rock. I
remember one of YC's LPs um very large
LPs said to me, historically the venture
market something like 97%
of returns are generated in the US
market. And I remember thinking to
myself like I always do like
that doesn't really align with my
current thesis so I don't believe it.
[laughter]
Discard opinion discarded.
You know it's a superpower for a sort of
founder.
[laughter]
>> I'm embarrassed I didn't realize how
good the US was. was so privileged to
live in a market that is kind of just
really big.
>> Yep.
>> That I could just blind myself my own
privilege and be like, "No, it's just as
easy to build a billion dollar company
somewhere else." And it's like,
is it? No, it's not. Not that you can't
do it. It's just not just as easy.
>> It's definitely not.
>> It's not just as easy. What were your
thoughts, by the way, back then? is like
we invested in a lot of international
companies.
>> Yeah, we did as a domestic um I think
>> some of them are doing really well. Some
of them are like we we just had a bunch
of Indian companies um doing
phenomenally well like growth just went
public which was a really big deal in
India so that's um counterex example but
yeah I think you're right I think I just
didn't know I think that a lot of folks
that are investors are basically
specialized finance people and I don't
mean that in a negative way
>> but it's I I just am stating the truth
which is if you you're like a stock
trader or like a private equity person I
think you're more attuned to this. Yes.
We were just startup founders. There was
never a time at our startups that we had
to worry about capital markets in India
and our US based startups like
[laughter]
this was just
>> we were just trying to fund smart
people.
>> But weirdly I think that's why we got to
fund grow and razor pay and nisho like
all of these decacorns in India.
>> Yes.
>> I think it's because we weren't
>> sophisticated enough to know that we're
not supposed to fund that stuff.
[laughter]
>> Like we didn't get the memo
>> not to fund these companies.
>> Yes. And so there's something beautiful
about being naive.
>> Yes.
>> Well, and I'm so happy we did it, right?
But this was researchable. We didn't
have Chad Jub. [laughter]
>> All right. Well, that's my first one. H
how about you? What's one that sticks
through your head?
>> One thing I remember is right when I was
starting at YC, like very, very, very
beginning.
>> Yes.
>> I remember um this is when PG was still
in charge of everything. Mhm.
>> I remember sitting down with Sam, who I
knew.
>> Mhm.
>> And Sam was like, "Oh, I'm leaving." And
I'm going to go work on nuclear power.
I'm going to do a nuclear power startup.
I've met all the small smartest reach
researchers in the world working on
nuclear.
>> Yes.
>> And I remember being like, "Oh, why?"
[laughter]
>> And again, I don't mean that in a
negative way, like as if I knew a lot
about it. I'm just like,
>> "That's random." Like, didn't you have
the like social network for boost mobile
phones? And this was during the like gig
economy.
>> This is like 2013. So in 2013 and he was
just like electricity and power is
everything. Yeah.
>> And that it's a total l that nuclear got
basically banned by governments
>> and that the key to the future is to
have unlimited electricity.
>> Yeah.
>> And I remember again not in a negative
way just being like
>> oh [laughter]
like like I think I just filed it away.
>> Yeah.
>> And neither was pro or anti I was very
neutral about this statement. And then a
few months later he came back to YC.
Yep.
>> And then he funded some nuclear
companies. Yep.
>> Which was pretty smart. And like now
they're huge companies. Yeah. And I
think he was right. Well, and even
despite like regardless of the companies
he funded,
>> the narrative today is
>> electricity is really important.
>> Yeah. Is the limiting factor for AI,
which we'll see
>> for like intelligence.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. It's as it
turns out, I think Sam was kind of
thinking about exactly the correct most
important thing.
>> Yeah. Just from a zoomed out
perspective. No, I think that's a that's
a really good one. Another one that you
bring up that kind of resonates with me
is this one around like smart people
win. And I spent a lot of time thinking
about this. I think that we don't talk
about this enough, but a lot of the
people we interact with were not cool in
high school. I [laughter] find that hard
to believe.
>> You're kidding me. Wait, really?
[laughter]
>> A lot of compensation for that. The prom
king, prom queen. [laughter]
>> I dare say some of them weren't even
cool in college.
>> Shocking. [laughter]
Shocking.
>> And I think that like a lot of people
were smart and they worked really hard
and they tried to get good grades and da
da da da when for a long time it wasn't
clear the payoff was right in front of
them. But then like you come to the Bay
Area and it does feel like this weird
community of smart people winning. It
has all these awkward side effects like
probably the general quality of sports
is less good here or there other
interesting side effects but like you do
feel something different about this
place. So flesh this out a little bit
more like what was the kind of
non-obvious thing here?
>> I feel like what I was taught was you
know a there's no such thing as
intelligence. Um,
[laughter]
>> okay.
>> You know, like, hey, let's just let's it
doesn't exist. Okay.
>> And then number two, you know, smart
people, whatever, but they're just
nerds. And ultimately,
>> yeah,
>> everyone is special in their own way.
>> And, you know, there's a lot of factors
that go into having an interesting life.
>> Sure.
>> And intelligence
>> is maybe in there somewhere, but it
doesn't really matter.
>> Yeah.
>> And I don't think that's true, Michael.
I guess my point is and and this isn't
even something that's restricted to just
uh tech.
>> Think about people that go into law or
people go into medicine or people that
go into finance. Like
>> kind of seems like the most ambitious
and smartest people to do the coolest
stuff. I would extend that further to
say
I think when you look at the people who
are actually winning in the macro, you
might be surprised at how uncool they
were for how long. And it's like the
people who you think are cool now were
not cool in high school. [laughter]
>> Yeah. And so, um, it's so interesting
how something changes where like the
population of cool people completely
swaps and like smarter people seem to
have much more of an advantage later.
Anything they do, even if it's strange.
>> Yes.
>> Like even if it's
>> Well, and I would even say strangely cuz
like I'm a huge basketball fan. People
talk about this in basketball a lot
where like the best players have high IQ
and you start looking at interviews like
there was this great LeBron James
interviewer who was like, "Hey, we're
going to run this play. It looked like
the team was prepared for it, so let's
just flip it and run on the different
side of the court." And he was like some
my team members just couldn't draw that
in their head and do and it's like
even as investors sometimes yes I don't
think I appreciated like I think I
thought who raised the most money
>> mattered more or like
>> I I don't know I thought a lot of
factors matter but it does kind of just
seem like
>> the most aggressive ambitious just
smartest people that can see things
other people can't see tend to do
better.
>> They tend to do better. They have an
advantage.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, and they have an
advantage that might overcome things
like did you grow up in a rich family?
Like other kind of weird starting
conditions. Um especially out here, like
especially out here. One that I I'm
still having trouble grasping. So when I
came out to the valley, we there were
some companies that were kind of
obviously losing out here, right? Uh
Yahoo would be a good consumer example.
Maybe HP would be a good enterprise
example. At the time, it was kind of
obvious to me. What's happened over the
last 15 years is it's very hard for me
to really identify the companies that
kind of look strong today but are slowly
rotting. But I know they exist, right?
Because like those companies, HP, Yahoo,
we can name others, looked incredibly
strong, were incredibly strong, but kind
of rotted from within. And
we have all these startups that are so
intimidated about these big companies,
but sometimes I think to myself like
which one of them is like a founder
taught me this phrase like a watermelon
like green on the outside, red on the
inside. Like you know like so how do you
think about this concept of like
companies right now that look strong,
great valuations, public doing great,
but like we're going to tell ourselves a
story 10 years from now. They just that
this was the time that they
>> I think the lesson is just it's a
topsyturvy world.
>> Yeah. And until you've seen it happen a
bunch of times, the things that seem
unassalably number one can just go away
and be gone in 10 years. All of internet
1.0, so much of that stuff just
evaporated.
>> Yeah.
>> And so companies like Google could
become completely irrelevant.
>> Yeah.
>> Or they could just become juggernauts
even more.
>> Yeah.
>> They're not like institutions that are
going to last no matter what happens.
That's what I'm trying to say. I think
they seem like infallible. They felt
less I don't know. They have to keep
winning.
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> Yes. Well, and there's some Intel versus
Nvidia. Intel
>> was like
>> an institution.
>> Yeah. Until it wasn't.
>> Yeah. And I think that maybe this is
different in other industries or other
parts of of America. When I started
thinking this way, Microsoft became so
much more of an impressive company
because I mean during this time when HP
and Yahoo were kind of declining, if you
had told me, hey, Microsoft is going to
be declining too, I would have believed
you.
>> Y
>> they did really good with cloud stuff.
>> Really good.
>> Well, and also they became like remember
when VS Code came out? Remember when
they bought like um
>> GitHub? You're just like
>> what? I'm so used to big companies
making the wrong decisions and then like
just you string a couple wins together
and it's like oh god at Microsoft scale.
So no, I think this is kind of like a a
an interesting one. I think if I was a
smartup founder, I'd be trying to figure
out are the incumbents in my space
rotting from the inside? Like are they
way more vulnerable than they look?
Another one I think that's kind of fun.
You touched on this. Let's talk about
hype cycles. Yeah,
>> cuz we've gone through so many hype
cycles. What's not obvious about hype
cycles? What are some hype cycles that
worked and that didn't? What do you what
do you see?
>> Yeah, I I think you know I remember
being a teenager and being on stock
trading message boards during the com
boom and do you remember the company
that made zip drives and jazz drives?
People way before these people were
born. I
>> Omega.
>> Yeah, that was a good one. It was like
one of the hottest stocks of all time.
And they made like basically floppy disc
drives, but
>> they don't know what that is either.
>> Yeah, you could just ask chat too.
>> Yeah, like a guy like uh like a USB
keys, a bit better.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> But not no USB keys are better, but like
a version of that. Yeah, imagine Dropbox
if it worked offline. [laughter]
>> Um anyway, it was one of like the
hottest stocks. So, I remember reading
about it and of course that went to
zero. That was not a good stock. So
look, I've seen so many cycles you can
start to recognize
>> that this is just part of reality is
that there are hype cycles and you go
through these different emotions about
this which is to be angry about it or
resentful or judgmental. Yeah.
>> No, it's just like it is. It's like
being mad about the weather. Like oh
>> I'm mad at the weather. It just happens.
>> And you want to identify the the things
on the way up and the things on the way
down. And um I think when you
acknowledge this stuff, you just have be
a lot more zen about the world.
>> It does seem like people get angry.
Hype cycles are very predictable. Like
you can't tell which one is necessarily,
but you know that there's always a hype
cycle or two going on, but people get
very angry about it, which I agree. Like
if it's always going to happen, it's
kind of
>> Yeah. It's just kind of part of the the
environment that we're in. And there's
often nice side effects of it and
there's not nice side effects of them.
And so I think it's just like a neutral
phenomenon. And so I would advocate
neutrality.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Versus anger.
Yeah. I think the the last one
>> for me and I think you brought up Sam
before. I've got a good Sam one. I think
I used to think a little too
mechanically about what it takes to
build a company. You need a big market.
You need a good product. You need to
price it correctly. any people who are
great founders. And I think that like
Sam, one of the things that he said that
kind of stuck is that like you have to
have kind of an ambition or a mission or
a goal that people can rally around that
fundamentally like a great company has
to attract a lot of great talent and all
kinds of talent, right? Whether it's
investing talent or technical talent or
um talent former customers going to pick
you. And like if what you're doing isn't
interesting, if it isn't
something that people can get excited
about, it's hard to rally that talent,
it's hard to rally those humans. And and
and it was like so funny because in my
mind before that, I was just kind of
like, well, obviously, you know, 2 plus
2 equals four. If this company has a
good product, we're going to work at it.
And then you start realizing like really
talented people have a choice. Yep.
>> Of where they put their time. And like
are you telling them we're going to do
something super exciting that might
change the world or are you not?
>> Are you going to do ad targeting stuff?
And the the counterintuitive thing that
Sam really got embedded in my brain is
like sometimes all it takes for us to do
things that look impossible is for there
to be attractive enough to attract the
smartest people.
>> Yes.
>> Like the smartest people can make the
impossible happen. And if you can't
attract the smartest people, you can't
even make the possible happen.
[laughter]
>> Well, it's like the Apollo moon landing.
And you think about it, that was a
miracle.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> But those people were pretty pumped to
be putting a man on the moon. Yes.
>> Like that was like a cool project.
>> Yes.
>> That people worked really hard.
>> A cool. That was the coolest [laughter]
coolest thing to work on.
>> Literally.
>> And it was like really hard. And what's
funny is like obviously he was telling
us this stuff and he went and lived that
advice.
>> He did. He did with open AI, right? Like
let's create intelligence. In hindsight
it just kind of sounds a little hokey,
but it's like oh you should have a
mission, right? Like that kind of
>> Yeah. Lame.
>> It's it's not that. I think it's just
like sometimes we have to remind
founders to just set their ambitions
higher. Like something that gets you
more excited is going to get other
people more excited. Like how can you be
excited about this for 10 years? versus
how can you be excited about this in the
amount of time it takes you to raise
your next round. And sometimes I think
that we feel like founders are being too
safe. Whereas I think in the past I
might have given people too safe advice.
>> Yeah.
>> I might have given people advice. I'm
like this is the safest way to get to
the series A. It's like is that is that
the end that we're going for here? Like
[laughter]
>> all right. So another one and I think
that you and I have experienced this so
often. We'll have a company come in and
they'll be like, "Well, if a startup,
I'm sorry, if a software company buys
our product, it allows them to not hire
five incremental engineers. Those
engineers costs a million dollars a
year. So like that means that like we
can charge $100,000. The company saves
900,000. This is incredible. The company
should make this trade every day of the
week. And so therefore, I guess
theoretically, a sizable software
company should have 200,000
different software vendors who each save
them a million dollars a year.
[laughter]
It's just that easy. It's just that
easy.
>> And we're just one of them.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
I think I did not quite understand.
>> Yeah. It's one of those things where in
a vacuum that is a reasonable first
principles argument, [laughter]
but in no way does that resemble actual
buying behavior. It's like it's defeated
by all the facts. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Like
reality calls
they say no. I'm not even saying I would
have intuited that myself, right? I'm
not being like, haha, how dare they
think that. I I
>> We fun.
Yes. Yes.
>> But for whatever reason, customers
like things that increase their revenue.
>> Yes.
>> And cause them to grow faster and are
willing to spend money on stuff that
causes them to grow faster
>> and and for whatever reason are not that
interested in cost cutting type
software, especially hard to measure
cost cutting type software. I didn't
understand this until I was on a public
company board and then it became so
clear I just like I kind of one day I
was just like oh no I didn't understand
a fundamental truth about business
as a as a startup investor fundamentally
the market is going to reward revenue
generation over cost cutting.
>> Yep. Because the market is always
betting on how much bigger you can get
over time and what's the potential for
you to be a company that's 10x bigger
and it's very hard to cost cut yourself
into being 10x bigger. The even more
counterintuitive thing the market will
value your attempts
to become 10x bigger
>> just trying you will get [laughter]
>> a boost in your stock price versus not
trying. So a lot of spending is rewarded
because like the market wants you to be
10x bigger, right?
>> Fundamentally once you appreciate this,
it's actually an eyeopening opportunity
because whereas there are probably a
thousand ways to help a company save a
million dollars when they're
sufficiently big, there aren't that many
ways to help them make a lot more
revenue.
>> Yep. And so you can kind of like
massively cut down the idea space or if
you want to save them a lot of money,
you have to realize how much money would
you have to save them
>> to be in a top five conversation when
we're trying to be measurable and
immediately provide value, not just
vibes based saving money.
>> Has to be like right tangible.
>> And one could argue maybe AWS made that
argument, right? like oh like we can
save you so much more money than if
you're running your own data
>> AWS was more expensive
>> but it was less logistically complex and
often customers will choose to pay more
>> yes
>> to reduce problems and so to not have to
deal with servers and hard drive
failures and all that crap
>> amortization
>> all that junk so they paid more for AWS
>> but man it it just obiated the need for
all this other complexity
>> well and it's interesting that you say
they paid more but I'd argue if you're
setting up a data center, you have to
think about the flow of money.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Like way less upfront investment
to get the benefit on AWS.
>> That's a great you have like way more
opportunity to offset those additional
money with with profits. And it doesn't
mean like every company to be a good
speed company have to figure out how to
make someone more money. It's just
surprising how much easier it is and
surprising how often in large companies
people are not asking how do we save
five engineers? [laughter]
Like how just often that's not the
conversation and and there's really no
world where those five engineers would
then be fired.
>> No, they
>> they just be put into something else.
>> Exactly. So just a different set. Long
story short, I know we make these
videos. There are a lot of things that
we didn't know [laughter]
that other people knew.
That's the way it goes. Great chat.
Thanks, man.